ich rufe jetzt auf den zusatzpunkt 9
beratung des antrags der fraktionen der
cdu/csu mit dem titel kinderschutz vor
datenschutz mit der speicherung von
ip-adressen sexuellen kindesmissbrauch
wirksam bekämpfen
für die aussprache wurde eine dauer von
68 minuten vereinbart
bevor ich die aussprache öffne wirklich
darum die platzwechsel
ja soweit also der bundeskanzler heute
morgen in brüssel nachher wird es eine
offizielle pressekonferenz mit ihm geben
aus brüssel die werden sie hierbei
phoenix natürlich live erleben können
und wir sind live zurück im deutschen
bundestag soeben hier die historische
abstimmung über die abschaffung des
paragraphen 219 a das werbeverbot ist
gefallen ärzte können künftig also für
abtreibungen auf ihren
internetseiten werben so und jetzt geht
es hier auch mit einem wichtigen thema
weiter kinderschutz vor datenschutz mit
der speicherung von ip-adressen
sexuellen kindesmissbrauch wirksam
bekämpfen das fordert die cdu csu
fraktion und bevor das hier losgehen
kann hatte ich ihn angekündigt dass die
fraktionsvorsitzenden der ampel parteien
etwas zu diesem abschaffung von 219
ansagen unterscheide ich jetzt mal raus
denn die haben sich im flur parlament
zögern dieser bundesregierung auf gerade
bei der bekämpfung von kindesmissbrauch
und kinderpornographie ist ein abwarten
aber fatal schon der römische kaiser
marc aurel wusst durch die tiere oft tut
auch der unrecht der nichts tut für das
unrecht nicht verbietet wenn er es kann
er befiehlt es meine damen und herren
der schutz unserer kinder ist uns nicht
nur in sonntagsreden ein wichtiges
anliegen sondern wir wollen die
schwächsten in unserer gesellschaft
tatsächlich und effektiv schützen
unser antrag hat eine ganz klare
zielsetzung es geht hier nicht um
allgemeine kriminalitätsbekämpfung
sondern es geht einzig und allein um den
kampf gegen den sexuellen missbrauch
unserer kinder jahr es fällt schwer das
auszubrechen zum teil von kleinstkindern
und säuglingen
wer meint es gebe hier keinen
handlungsbedarf ignoriert offenbar die
dramatische entwicklung in diesem
bereich leiter polizeilichen
kriminalstatistik 20 21 haben sich die
fälle der verbreitung des erwerbs des
besitzers der herstellung von
kinderpornografie mehr als verdoppelt
auf inzwischen 39.000 fälle und hinter
jedem bild hinter jedem video steht ein
ekelhafter realer missbrauch jedes opfer
solcher delikte ist eines zu viel aber
die nochmalige steigerung der fälle das
erschüttert und alarmiert uns wir als
cdu csu werden es nicht hinnehmen wenn
immer mehr kinder zu opfern werden meine
damen und herren
was müssen wir deshalb tun für einen
besseren schutz unserer kinder natürlich
brauchen wir mehr personal so wie es in
nrw etwa innenminister herbert reul
vorgemacht hat die polizeibeschäftigten
in diesem bereich nahezu vervierfacht
und der mit laub und
die ermittler brauchen für ihre
unglaubliche belastende arbeit noch
bessere technische unterstützung etwa
durch den einsatz von künstlicher
intelligenz die relevante bilder
vorsortiert aber personal und technik
alleine reichen eben nicht wir brauchen
vor allem auch die notwendigen und
wirksamen rechtlichen werkzeug im kampf
gegen kindesmissbrauch
zur aufklärung solcher taten sind wir
angewiesen auf hinweise vor allem des us
amerikanischen national center for
missing and exploited children denn die
internet anbieter teilen diesem center
die strafrechtlich relevanten
sachverhalte mit während bei uns die
meldepflicht nach dem netzwerk durch
jetzt muss gesetz faktisch auf eis liegt
mehrere 2009 10 waren das 16 8 millionen
hinweise auf potenzielle straftaten
weltweit 2020 bereits 21,4 millionen
bei sage und schreibe neun 10.150
hinweisen an das bundeskriminalamt
führte eine bestands datenabfrage den
letzten fünf jahren nicht zu einer
identifizierung des benutzten
anschlusses und das nur deshalb nicht
weil in diesen fällen als einzige ansatz
die ip-adresse zur verfügung stand diese
aber in unserem land nicht mehr bei den
providern gespeichert war so jetzt kann
man das auf die gerichte urteile zur
vorratsdatenspeicherung schieben sich
als politiker achselzuckend zurücklegen
oder man kann den spielraum den die
rechtsprechung uns lässt konsequent zu
gunsten der kinder nutzen wir haben uns
für letzteres entschieden mal mutter
aber spielräume nutzen heißt bei uns
wirksam handeln denn keine missbrauchten
kind dies mit reiner symbolpolitik
geholfen
symbolpolitik ist es wenn man etwas
salbungsvoll über ein kinder grundrecht
redet aber sich in die büsche schlägt
wenn es ernst wird beim schutz von
kindern die ganz besonders unser aller
hilfe brauchen hier an du bist
und symbolpolitik ist es auch wenn
fdp-justizminister seit
leutheuser-schnarrenberger
gebetsmühlenartig das heil in einem
sogenannten quick freeze modell suchen
danach wären verbindungsdaten erst nach
einem verdachtsfall gespeichert ein
verdacht wird aber häufig erst erkennbar
wenn die daten ja schon längst gelöscht
sind das kennen wir leider alle von zu
hause wenn das kühlfach leer ist kann
man eben auch nichts mehr rausholen
meine damen und herren zu beruhigen sie
vielleicht ihr schlechtes gewissen
geholfen wird dabei aber kaum einem
opfer
wir wollen den vom missbrauch
betroffenen kindern spürbar und effektiv
helfen indem wir
telekommunikationsanbieter verpflichten
zu einer sechsmonatigen speicherung nur
von ip adressen zum zwecke
ausschließlich der bekämpfung von
schweren straftaten gegen kinder mit der
zweifachen einschränkungen gegenüber der
geltenden verkehrs datenspeicherung
knüpfen wir direkt an die urteile des
europäischen gerichtshofs und des
bundesverfassungsgerichts an wir stellen
damit die verfassungs und europarecht
konformität dieses modells sicher
bemerkenswert ist bemerkenswert ist dass
die innenministerin inzwischen erkannt
hat dass diese streng zweckgebunden
ip-adressen speicherung richtig ist und
eben etwas ganz anderes ist als die
allgemeine vorratsdatenspeicherung es
wäre schön wenn auch der justizminister
sich diesem lernprozess nicht länger
verschließen
und es täte der sache gut wenn auch die
ampel fraktionen sich nicht reflexhaft
in kampfrhetorik gegen vermeintliche
vorratsdatenspeicherung ergehen sondern
sich dem antrag in der sache einmal
widmen
ich fordere daher die linke seite dieses
hauses auf helfen sie den kindern die
leider auch genau in diesem moment
während wir hier heute morgen
debattieren missbraucht und dabei
aufgenommen werden für uns als
gesetzgeber ist es nur eine kleine
rechtsänderung für viele kinder kann es
die rettung aus unvollständig sein meine
damen und herren
nächster redner für die spd fraktion
sebastian fiedler
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte damen und herren ich
will versuchen nicht ganz so
parteipolitisch polemisch zu beginnen
und der stelle will aber dennoch am ende
darauf durchaus nochmal zu sprechen
kommen und will das thema etwas breiter
aufmachen will zunächst einmal am anfang
und am breitesten über die opfer
sprechen anschließend über mittleren und
ermittler und andere die mit dem thema
zu tun haben über die täter nur ganz
kurz und dann über die politiker am ende
zunächst noch einmal würde ich sie immer
betten schauen sie sich mal um die im
plenarsaal schon aus dem foyer meine
damen und herren springen wir wieder in
den plenarsaal die ampel feiert die
streichung von 219 a im moment gibt es
100000 abtreibungen das hat sich so
eingespielt über die letzten jahre man
kann gespannt sein ob diese zahl
erhalten bleibt oder ob es doch einen
effekt gibt der bundestag jedenfalls
debattiert in diesen sekunden über einen
antrag der cdu csu mit dem namen
kinderschutz vor datenschutz mit der
speicherung von ip-adressen sexuellen
kindesmissbrauch wirksam bekämpfen die
in wermelskirchen aufgedeckten fälle von
schwersten sexuellen kindesmissbrauch
haben eine alte debatte neu entfacht
nämlich die über längere speicherfristen
von verbindungsdaten um täter
identifizieren zu können und der
kinderschutz sei so wichtig dass eben
diese spannende daten länger gespeichert
werden sollen das ist zumindest die
meinung der cdu csu bundestagsfraktion
seit wenigen minuten redet jetzt hier
der zweite reden eine debatte nämlich
für die spd der sprecher für
kriminalpolitik sebastian fiedler
säugling besprechen über penetriert
säuglinge mehr als die hälfte der opfer
ist jünger als drei jahre alt gewesen es
geht um kinder mit behinderungen
manche kinder und jugendliche müssen
über jahre
sexualisierte gewalt ertragen
hinzu kommt noch das ganze thema was mir
noch gar nicht ausgeben ich besprochen
haben das thema der misshandlungen zwei
bis drei kinder kommen pro woche im
durchschnitt über die letzten jahre zu
tode etwa 4000 fälle stehen in der
statistik körperliche misshandlung jedes
jahr
europol nur ein kurzer blick was so die
szene so ausmacht diese fürchterliche
szene spricht davon macht deutlich
welche bedeutung peer to peer netzwerke
haben darknet netzwerke computer
umgebungen die also nach wie vor noch
die wichtigste plattform sind für den
zugang zu diesen darstellungs material
und eben auch trotzdem noch teilweise
nicht kommerziell dem großen bereich
verbreitet wird aber teilweise eben gibt
es schnittstellen zu kommerziellen
verbreitung für straftäter höchste
anonymisierung das live-streaming darauf
möchte ich ihre aufmerksamkeit rechnen
ist ein neuer trend muss man leider
sagen bei dem kinder in übersee
misshandelt werden und von westlichen
menschen hier wird sich das entsprechend
angeschaut es gibt hinweise darauf dass
die kommerzielle nutzung dieser perfiden
missbrauch situation dazu beiträgt dass
mir dieser darstellungen im umlauf sind
wir haben einen live fern missbrauch der
sich als trend abzeichnet wir haben die
situation durch die viele verbreitung
von smartphones dass kinder und
jugendliche dazu angeleitet werden
selber von sich aufnahmen zu machen zur
sexuellen erpressung dient das ganze und
wir haben gott sei dank das ist
sozusagen das nächste kapitel dazu will
ich durchaus mal zwei sätze sagen viele
ermittlerinnen und damit viele menschen
die sich darum kümmern dieses zeug
aufzuarbeiten die die töne und die
schreie mit in den schlaf nehmen wir
haben viele die in jugendämtern bei lg
aus mit diesen themen zu tun haben wir
einen therapeutinnen und therapeuten die
sich um die traumatisierung kümmern wir
haben engagierte betroffene und wir
haben eine neue missbrauchsbeauftragte
und ich glaube an dieser stelle
zumindest für diese menschen in der
bundesrepublik können wir durchaus einen
applaus an dieser stelle macht aus
großem dank und
wir haben die täter und ich aus guten
gründen werde ich da nur wenig zeit
darauf verwenden die täter strategien
sind vom richtiger bedeutung die
vernetzung spielt eine rolle sie
tauschen sich darüber aus was passiert
wenn jemand erwischt wird sie lernen
forensisch daran und wir haben das habe
ich angedeutet das ist der entscheidende
punkt und ich habe durchaus die
gewichtung meines vertrages gut gewählt
die politikerinnen und politiker und wir
haben eine ampel koalition die sich
diesem ganzen thema deswegen habe ich
sehr viel zeit auf die darstellung der
unterschiedlichen opfer szenarien der
unterschiedlichen szenarien aufgewandt
wir haben politiker in der
ampelkoalition die das thema ganz ganz
breit angehen und die insbesondere auf
diejenigen hören die entweder betroffene
sind die kennen nämlich die täter
strategien äußerst gut und die bei den
ermittlern und mitte arbeiten jetzt bin
ich einer der da genau aus diesem
bereich herkommt und wir tun deswegen
sehr viel der pakt für den rechtsstaat
steht steht im koalitionsvertrag wird
aus verhandelt deswegen wird es nicht
nur lauten ist fahren sondern auch in
anderen bundesländern hoffentlich mehr
engagierte menschen geben die dort in
diesen bereichen arbeiten
das bundeskriminalamt weg gestärkt wir
machen was bei der technik wir machen
ein zieht das gesetz und versuchen dort
technisch weiter zu unterstützen wir
haben in unserer fraktion gleich mehrere
arbeitsgruppen zu diesem thema
eingerichtet um es bereit anzugehen wir
haben uns mit der
missbrauchsbeauftragten hessen klaus
getroffen wenn sie wissen wollen was
noch alles zu tun ist dann rate ich
ihnen schauen sie sich ihre interviews
an und schauen sie was dort alles zu tun
ist ich kann jedenfalls von unserer
fraktion aussagen dass sie unsere
vollste rückendeckung und unterstützung
hat für ihre vorhaben die sie schon
öffentlich kundgetan hatten die sie
weiter noch vorantreibt zwei beispiele
dafür auf der einen seite das engagement
für betroffenen räte in den ländern auf
der einen seite und auf der anderen
seite werden sie noch in diesem herbst
eine groß angelegte kampagne sehen die
die sensibilisierung der bevölkerung
hervorbringen soll
und deswegen das kann ich ihnen nicht
ersparen hegerings treffen sie auf einen
punkt wo sie wissen wo es einigkeit an
bestimmten stellen gibt emotional
vergangenheit häufig darüber
ausgetauscht aber was ich ihm vorwerfe
ist eine bestimmte passage im antrag bei
der sie so tun als würde jetzt hier die
ganze ampelkoalition sich vor diesem
thema wegducken weil es in dieser einen
frage und das zerren sie sozusagen sehr
billig in die öffentlichkeit zwei
stellungnahmen des bundes
justizministerin und der innenministerin
sie nutzen diesen teil zulasten
derjenigen die ich alle aufgezählt habe
parteipolitisch aufs übelste aus und das
werde ich
sie stellen ein zusammenhang eher der da
bedeutet durch die alpin adressen sei
das thema zu lösen und deswegen will ich
sozusagen zwei anmerkungen noch machen
meine ganz persönliche haltung den
diskutieren wir durchaus ist dass wir
die möglichkeiten die der europäische
gerichtshof uns gegeben hat nutzen
sollten und ip adressen speichern so
nicht bin absolut auf der seite unserer
bundesinnenminister können aber sicher
sein dass wir zuerst in der ampel
diskutieren auf der grundlage der
argumente die wir da haben das müssen
wir nicht anhand ihres antrages hier
machen letzter satz gehen sie mit mir
vielleicht den richter sind wir
hoffentlich alle einig und folgen der
missbrauchsbeauftragten die da sagt wir
müssen die tabus reißen und deswegen
habe ich versucht möglichst konkreten
ist darf kein gesellschaftliches tabu
sein sie vergleicht es zurecht mit dem
brandschutz wir müssen über all die
fragen die so schmerzlich und übels in
der mitte unserer gesellschaft quer
durch alle gesellschaftlichen schichten
vorhanden sind wir müssen ihnen ins auge
schauen also reden wir über
sexualisierte gewalt an kindern und
jugendlichen wie über den brandschutz
und folgen ihrer idee und ich hoffe auf
große einigkeit in dieser frage
zumindest lassen sie uns das also ohne
ideologie an dieser stelle weiter
treiben und den opfer rinnen und opfern
den vorzug geben
der bundestag debattiert hier über einen
antrag der cdu csu fraktion kinderschutz
vor datenschutz und der nächste return
kommt von der afd gereon bollmann
frau präsidentin meine damen und herren
die alten griechen lernens was von dem
vorliegenden antrag zu erhalten ist ein
trojanisches pferd
es schaffen aus feinstem holz die augen
aus obsidian und bernstein die zähne aus
elfenbein und die mähne aus echtem
pferdehaar hier heißt das pferd schutz
der kinder vor sexuellem missbrauch
die in seinem inneren versteckten
krieger nennt man heute
vorratsdatenspeicherung
nein dr krings liebe kollegen von der
union auf diese leim ute werden wir
ihnen nicht gehen
der missbrauch von kindern ist eines der
widerlichsten arten von kriminalität
diese delikte schreien geradezu nach
strafverfolgung aber
damit eignen sie sich auch besonders gut
mit ihr andere ziele zu verstecken die
speicherung von daten auf vorrat kann
nämlich missbraucht werden und sie ist
auch ungeeignet sie führt unter
beachtung der informationellen
selbstbestimmung was die ip-adressen
angeht auch nicht zu erfolgen die
gespeicherten daten sind stets objekte
von begehrlichkeiten laden also zum
missbrauch ein sie müssen wissen dass
bei einer durchsuchung oftmals so
genannte
zufallsfunde gemacht werden der
staatsanwalt spricht dabei von beifang
man sucht offiziell nach einer mücke
will aber den elefanten finden nach
unserer strafprozessordnung sind diese
elefanten dann auch verwertbare
nummer auf den punkt gebracht was ist
eigentlich mit politischer kriminalität
staatsanwaltschaften dies übrigens ein
verstoß gegen eu-recht sind immer noch
dem jeweiligen justizminister gegenüber
weisungsgebunden
es besteht also die versuchung auf die
gespeicherten adressen zuzugreifen und
auszuspähen was sich bei dem politischen
gegner denn so alles finden lässt nein
ich weiß doch niemand von ihnen hier
kämen natürlich auf die idee so was auch
nur zu denken aber es besteht immerhin
die möglichkeit dazu
außerdem findet man in der regel die
täter nicht wir kennen noch alle die so
genannten virtuellen privaten netzwerken
kurz vpn auch die kriminellen kennen sie
und werden sie nutzen sollten die ip
adressen gespeichert werden die mehrheit
dieser täter bewegt sich außerdem im
darknet auch dort kann man sie mit den
ip-adressen nicht aufspüren
mit der regelung der union bewirken wir
gar nichts die speicherung ist
ungeeignet ein solches mittel ist aber
bei grundrechtseingriffen stets
unverhältnismäßig und damit
verfassungswidrig
wir wollen den kinderschutz im netz
dagegen ernsthaft und wirksam verbessern
wir wollen die gebündelten
arbeitsgruppen bei den cyber crime
staatsanwaltschaften verstärken die
staatsanwälte aus solchen arbeitsgruppen
die es in einigen bundesländern schon
seit längerem gibt haben auch erfolg sie
haben die technische expertise und sie
haben die ressourcen auch große
plattformen und dort mengen zu
bearbeiten sie haben auch die
möglichkeit
verdeckte ermittler einzusetzen dies
kostet natürlich alles geld wir müssen
dieses geld auch in die hand nehmen wenn
wir unseren kindern wirklich helfen
wollen
liebe kollegen von der union die
amerikaner haben eine treffende
bezeichnung für
ausgeprägtes wollen ohne zu können
2 vielen dank
[Applaus]
nächster redner für die fraktion bündnis
90/die grünen marcel emmerich
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
sexueller missbrauch sexuelle ausbeutung
und seine darstellung und verbreitung
müssen entschieden bekämpft werden
gerade auch online daran gibt es
überhaupt gar keinen zweifel
aber ich muss sagen ich finde es
respektlos und in farmen dass die union
hier mit ihrem antragstext unterstellt
wir in den koalitionsfraktionen würden
den kinderschutz auf die leichte
schulter nehmen und ich muss sagen ich
bin seit einem halben jahr vater und ich
finde das ist nicht in ordnung wie sie
hier argumentieren
jeder einzelne fall steht für ein
zerstörtes kinder leben dann gibt es
nichts zu rütteln abscheulich für
abscheuliche verbrechen gegen kinder
müssen wir mit aller rechtsstaatlichen
entschlossenheit entgegen treten dafür
braucht es mehr und eine bessere
vernetzung prävention kooperation
zwischen den jugendämtern eine
schnellere lösung eine bessere
ausstattung für die ermittler innen und
vor allem verfassungsrechtlich tragbare
lösungen für unsere strafe hörens
gehören
aber all das
das spiegelt dieser antrag nicht wieder
und immer wieder bringen sie dazu
beiträge ein die eine unverhältnismäßige
überwachung der bürgerinnen und bürger
legitimieren soll meine damen und herren
von der union seien sie doch mal ehrlich
und benennen es mit dem begriff den sie
im kern fordern sich aber offensichtlich
nicht trauen zu schreiben oder hier
offen zu sagen sie fordern die
anlasslose vorratsdatenspeicherung die
vorratsdatenspeicherung mit der sie
während ihrer 16 jährigen regierungszeit
zu recht immer und immer wieder vor
gerichten gescheitert sind wenn so ihre
antwort auf schlimmste verbrechen
aussieht erweisen sind den opfern einen
bärendienst das ist keine kluge politik
das ist eine politik die
rechtssicherheit und rechtsstaatlichkeit
nicht so genau nimmt ihre forderung ihre
forderung ist die fortsetzung der
politik der scherbenhaufen
scherbenhaufen die wir jetzt hier als
koalitionsfraktionen zusammenkehren
müssen und das machen wir nach und nach
und am ende wissen sie was ihr am ende
haben dann haben wir eine
vorausschauende und faktenorientierte
sicherheitspolitik die auf bestehende
sicherheitspolitische gefahren
zielgerichtet antwortet sie gerichtet
antwortet und mit dieser rechtssicheren
politik und gesetzgebung praxis leisten
wir einen beitrag für die demokratie und
bringen obendrein noch ein
entlastungspaket ein entlastungsprogramm
für karlsruhe für das
bundesverfassungsgericht auf den weg
weil die werden weniger mit uns zu tun
haben
und jetzt kann man sich ja schon auch
sehr wundern nachdem sie jahrelang in
regierungsverantwortung gesagt haben sie
können gerade nicht an einer neuen
regelung arbeiten weil sie auf das
urteil gewartet haben präsentieren sie
hier jetzt kurz vor dem zu erwartenden
urteil zur verkorksten deutschen
regelung diesen halbgaren antrag dabei
sind auch die strafverfolgungsbehörden
viel kreativer als die union schauen sie
doch dafür zb mal nach schließlich
holstein sie gibt es ein positionspapier
der gdp vier wichtige stichpunkte sind
darin personalbedarf sachausstattung
gesundheitsprävention wertschätzung das
sind dinge auf die es ankommt
wir haben mit den quick freeze verfahren
einen vernünftigen vorschlag einen
adäquaten vorschlag auf dem tisch und im
koalitionsvertrag übrigens seit neuestem
auch im koalition zu tragen schleswig
holstein bei schwarz-grün also kamen sie
vielleicht schon mal gehört und da
schaffen wir dass das hier mit dem
erfordernis des anfangsverdachts und
einer richterlichen anordnung
rechtsstaatliche leitplanken einziehen
der weg ist also geebnet wir bringen
wirksame strafverfolgung und grundrechts
sicherung in einklang lassen sie uns
doch vernünftig bleiben und vernünftig
darüber reden endlich die erkenntnis
gewinnen die anlasslose
vorratsdatenspeicherung in deutschland
zu den akten zu legen vielen dank
[Applaus]
ich hab gesagt vielen dank herr villiger
inzwischen stehen
also die präsident ist hat sich nicht
geschlechtlich verwandelt sondern ich
bin der nachfolger
nächsten dass die kollegin anke
domscheit-berg fraktion die linke
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte präsident lieber
kolleginnen
2020 gab es über 14.000 anzeigen wegen
sexualisierter gewalt an kindern und
fast 19.000 mal anzeigen zur verbreitung
von kind von bildern dieser gewalt und
ja es muss viel mehr getan werden um
kinder wirksam davor zu schützen
es braucht mehr zuwendung stärkung von
jugendämtern
schulsozialarbeit auch aufklärung von
eltern und kindern selber denn in meinem
wahlkreis kenne ich mehrere fälle wo
opfer lehrkräfte und eltern völlig
ratlos waren man kann auch digital zum
beispiel online wachen für minderjährige
einrichten man kann melde buttons
verpflichtend haben wo man mit einem
klick automatisch beweise sichern kann
für die strafverfolgung oder auch hilfe
bekommt von ombudsperson bei
strafverfolgungsbehörden könnte man
müsste man mehr kompetenzen und
ressourcen zur digitalen beweissicherung
haben und natürlich auch mehr personal
aber nichts davon fordert die cdu in
ihrem antrag schreibt dessen der immer
gleiche respekt mehr massenüberwachung
stadt prävention sie will eine
vorratsdatenspeicherung von ip adressen
für sechs monate schon 2007 hat die cdu
die vorratsdatenspeicherung eingeführt
der ogh hat sie zum glück gekippt
die ampel hat sich im koalitionsvertrag
ganz klar von der
vorratsdatenspeicherung verabschiedet
das ist sehr gut so und erfüllt auch
eine forderung der linksfraktion aber
im koalitionsvertrag steht auch ein
recht auf verschlüsselung das aktuell
durch eine europäische verordnung die
auch den schutz von kindern vor
sexualisierter gewalt zum ziel hat
gefährdet ist auch diese europäische
verordnung enthält in ihrem entwurf
keinen einzigen effektiven vorschlag für
prävention nur strafverfolgung und das
mittels der sogenannten chat kontrolle
denn sie verlangt eine durchsuchung
aller messenger dienste auch
verschlüsselter dienste und potenziell
verdächtige inhalte zu finden mit dieser
einhergehenden schwächung der
verschlüsselung würde aber auch die
sicherheit unserer kommunikation
gefährdet und auch für dritte angreifbar
und weil algorithmen fehlerhaft sind
wird es tausende falsche verdachtsfälle
geben und die überlasteten ermittlern
müssen sich dann auch noch mit harmlosen
fotos planschen der kinder im garten von
oma beschäftigen den elternteilen den
familien chat geteilt hat zeit die
ermittlern fehlt
tausende male würde die privatsphäre
minderjähriger dadurch zusätzlich
verletzt das ist nicht nur nicht
hilfreich das verschlechtert den
kinderschutz deshalb haben nicht nur 160
ganzen folgen eine petition
unterschrieben und über 90 grundrechts
organisationen einen offenen brief
verfasst auch
kinderschutzorganisationen halten die
chat kontrolle für unangemessen und
wenig hilfreich deshalb beantragt die
linksfraktion dass die bundesregierung
in brüssel ganz klar gegen die chep
kontrolle und jeder art der schwächung
des rechts auf verschlüsselung vorliegt
und stattdessen für wirksame maßnahmen
kämpft die kinder besser schützen und
liebe kolleginnen helfen bitte auch sie
alle mit notieren sie sich den link www
gefangen im netz.de dort findet sich
informationsmaterial
konkrete hilfsangebote und ein wirklich
großartiger aufklärungsfilm zeigen sie
den überall in ihren schulen es gibt in
jeder klasse gefährdete kinder für die
diese information hoffentlich noch
gerade zur rechten zeit kommen
www gefangen im netz de ich dass ich
selber noch mal zum schluss möchte ich
ein allerletztes mal am ende meiner rede
zu 219 a reden es ist tatsächlich
geschafft vielen dank auch an die ampel
dafür beim recht auf verschlüsselung und
der absage an vorratsdatenspeicherung
erwarte ich aber auch dass man den
koalitionsvertrag erfüllt vielen dank
er sagte anke domscheit-berg für die
linke die digital politische sprecherin
der fraktion
zunächst fällt das wort wenn ich ihn
aufrufe der kollege konstantin fdp
fraktion ist der stellvertretende
fraktionsvorsitzende
herr präsident meine damen und herren
der sexuelle missbrauch an kindern und
die verbreitung von
missbrauchsdarstellungen gehören zu den
schrecklichsten straftaten die es gibt
und deswegen haben wir alle gemeinsam in
diesem haus das ziel die täter zu finden
und zu bestrafen und es ist eine gute
nachricht dass in der polizeilichen
kriminalstatistik für das jahr 20 21 die
gerade veröffentlicht worden ist die
aufklärungsquote im bereich der
missbrauchsdarstellungen bei
92,3 prozent liegt diese statistik hilft
denjenigen nicht die im dunkelfeld sind
diese statistik hilft denen 7,7 prozent
nicht bei dem missbrauchsdarstellungen
eben nicht verfolgt werden konnten aber
es zeigt uns doch dass in diesem land
bei einer so schrecklichen straftat
vergleichsweise viele ermittlungserfolge
erzielt werden das haben wir den
beamtinnen und beamten zu verdanken die
sich dieses widerlicher material ansehen
müssen und ihnen gilt unser dank liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
und natürlich müssen wir hier gemeinsam
auch darüber sprechen welche daten zur
verfügung stehen um die täter zu finden
und zu bestrafen es wäre aber verfehlt
eine erneute diskussion über die
vorratsdatenspeicherung zu beginnen denn
die vorratsdatenspeicherung gibt es
längst sie steht im gesetz sie kann aber
von den ermittlern nicht eingesetzt
werden weil die regelung mehrfach von
deutschen und europäischen gerichten für
unanwendbar erklärt worden ist und weil
sie die grundrechte verletzt und es ist
auch gut so dass diese regelungen nicht
angewandt werden kann denn in einer
offenen gesellschaft in einer liberalen
demokratien in einer freien gesellschaft
braucht der staat eine begründung damit
er anlasslos die daten aller menschen
speichern kann und das schlichte bewegen
im internet ist keine ausreichende
begründung das macht noch keinen täter
aus den menschen die sich im internet
bewegen und deswegen wollen wir die
anlasslose vorratsdatenspeicherung als
ampel abschaffen und meine damen und
herren liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
wir werden das tun indem wir eine der
ausnahmen nutzen die der europäische
gerichtshof zulässt und das ist die
einführung einer regelung zur
anlassbezogenen speicherung von daten
dem einfrieren nach einem richterlichen
beschluss das ist der richtige weg das
werden wir machen und da sehen sie schon
dass wir auch die vorgaben des
europäischen gerichtshofs beachten
werden soweit sich die vorgaben des
europäischen gerichtshofs auch
erstrecken auf die ip-adresse sei an
dieser stelle gesagt dass die ip-adresse
in deutschland längst gespeichert wird
und zwar mindestens für sieben tage und
die 92,3 prozent die wir haben die
kommen doch daher dass wir es geschafft
haben über bessere verfahren innerhalb
weniger tage von dem hinweis aus den usa
zur zuständigen staatsanwaltschaft und
dann weiter zur durchsuchung und zur
beschlagnahme zu kommen diese verfahren
müssen noch schneller werden da arbeiten
wir gerne gemeinsam dran bekämpfen wir
gemeinsam kindesmissbrauch erhöhen wir
die aufklärungsquote die dank der
beamtin und schon sehr hoch ist aber
schützen wir auch die grundrechte aller
unbescholtenen bürgerinnen und bürger in
diesem land die mit diesen widerlichen
taten nichts zu tun haben herzlichen
dank
vielen dank der konzern hat es
angesprochen die jüngste
kriminalstatistik die hat ergeben dass
im vergangenen jahr die polizei in
deutschland deutlich mehr
missbrauchsdarstellungen an kindern
erfasst hat als 2020 im durchschnitt
sind es 49 minderjährige opfer pro tag
mehr als 39.000 fälle wurden den
behörden bekannt wie diese
sonderauswertung der polizeilichen
kriminalstatistik zeigt wie
kindesmissbrauch zu den wieder berichten
taten zählen die es gibt sich von allen
meinen vorrednern dann wenn es konkret
wird etwa bei der speicherung von
ip-adressen dann verweigert sich die
komplette ampel und das ist nicht
akzeptabel und
das fehlende interesse der ampel
koalition zeigt sich auch dadurch dass
keine der betroffenen minister hier
anwesend ist weder familie noch innen
noch justiz und alle unentschuldigt ihre
kolleginnen kollegen der ampel
sie haben sich in ihrem
koalitionsvertrag selbst fesseln
angelegt beschränkt auf die
anlassbezogene speicherung
beziehungsweise quick freeze nur alle
fachleute auch der bund deutscher
kriminalbeamter herr kollege fiedler
sagt uns dass dieses quick freeze
keinesfalls ausreichend ist um die täter
tatsächlich zu erwischen und vor allem
zukünftige taten zu verhindern und wenn
sie auf diesem stand bleiben dann
schützen sie die schwächsten in unserer
gesellschaft nicht sie liebe kollegen
kollegen der ampel sie lassen sie im
stich und das hat erfreulicherweise
habt ihr schon begrüßen
erfreulicherweise die innenministerin
erkannt und zwar nach einem besuch des
bka in wiesbaden ende mai wo genau diese
ermittlung ihr die situation dargestellt
haben und präsident münch sie auch
aufgefordert hat wird schon seit langer
zeit tut diese ip adressen speichern zu
können auswerten zu können und zwar
mindestens
rückseitig um rückseitig um sechs monate
ich komme gleich nochmal sie ihnen herr
kollege herr kollege peter und da ist
die ministerin auch weiter als es die
ampel ist denn die ampel herr kollege
coole bleibt mit dem was sie gesagt
haben auch mit dem was im
koalitionsvertrag steht hinter den
möglichkeiten zurück die der ogh uns
gewehrt und der euro ist nun wirklich
nicht bekannt dass er im
datenschutzrecht lexware oder
grundrechte missachten würden erst in
einem urteil vom april zu einem fall aus
irland hatte erklärt dass bei schwersten
straftaten das sind doch wohl
kindesmissbrauch und kinderpornographie
die speicherung auch die rückseitige
speicherung von ip-adressen zulässig ist
er sieht nämlich gerade in dieser
speicherung der ip-adressen einen
geringeren grundrechtseingriffen
deswegen einen geringeren schutzbedarf
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
und
das selbsternannte
freiheitskämpfer
justizminister buschmann die fdp
insbesondere die grünen die sitzen hier
schon seit jahr und tag im
bremserhäuschen aber herr kollege
fiedler deswegen komme ich nochmal
zurück auch die spd wir haben nämlich
schon 2020 winzer vorwurf kommt warum
haben sie es nicht schon lange gemacht
2020 beim letzten gesetzpaket zum
zur bekämpfung von kindesmissbrauch
genau diesen vorschlag den wir heute
singulär herbringen der damaligen
justizministerin
lamprecht unterbreitet die es dann für
die spd
abgelehnt hat wir hätten das schon haben
können in der alten koalition wenn die
spd mit gemachte der kollege vielleicht
ist es an ihnen gemeinsam mit
innenministerin endlich vernunft in
dieser koalition zu sorgen und die
möglichkeit der speicherung von
ip-adressen zu erwirken
und ein letztes wort
ein letztes wort insbesondere die
kollegen der fdp kollege coole wir
hatten ja schon bei den
haushaltsplanberatungen über eine
zwischenfrage von mir uns über das thema
ausgetauscht und ich fand es schon
bemerkenswert dass sie so mit einem wort
nein gesagt haben zu der frage nein
gesagt haben zu der frage ob man
ip-adressen rückseitig speichern kann er
wohl aber ich fand es so dass sie auch
nicht noch mal drüber nachgedacht haben
reflektiert haben sondern nur auf die
vergangenheit der letzten
regierungsjahre eingegangen sind das
finde ich das sage ich ihnen nicht
verantwortungsbewusst und jetzt halte
ich ihnen den text vor denn sie vor
einem jahr ins grundgesetz schreiben
wollten jedes kind hat das recht auf
entwicklung zu einer
eigenverantwortlichen persönlichkeit ja
das hat es aber missbrauch macht es
weitergeht unmöglich die körperlichen
und seelischen schäden sind so schlimm
dass die kinder ein leben lang darunter
leiden und sie lassen diese schwächsten
diese kinder entsteht wenn sie aus
ideologischen gründen aus ideologischen
gründen die möglichkeiten die gh1 event
gewährt die ganzen herzlich danke
da die ampel koalition die hat sich in
den koalitionsvertrag geschrieben das
sogenannte quick-freeze-verfahren statt
der vorratsdatenspeicherung dabei werden
nämlich internetprovider bei dem quick
freeze verfahren erst bei einem
anfangsverdacht aufgefordert daten zu
einzelnen teilnehmern für einen
bestimmten zeitraum zu speichern
jetzt hören wir alle kauf sei für die
spd
kinderschutz vor datenschutz mit der
speicherung von ip-adressen sexuellen
kindesmissbrauch wirksam bekämpfen was
ein titel hier werden hohe güter
gegeneinander ausgespielt und das mit
dem klaren ziel anders kann ich mir
nicht erklären akteurinnen zu
diskreditieren die sich für datenschutz
einsetzen
dafür eignet sich das thema kinderschutz
besonders gute niemand kann gegen den
schutz von kindern sein ich bin es auch
nicht denn kinder vor allem kleinkinder
das hat der kollege fiedler von gesagt
und eine besonders hohe brücke das thema
ist deswegen hoch emotional und die
argumentation scheint im ersten band
simple und so kommen sie liebe
kolleginnen von der union dabei wieder
und wieder auf die eine oder andere form
der vorratsdatenspeicherung zurück eine
mittel das seit mehr 20 jahren durch
dieses haus geistert es war schon damals
nicht akzeptabel und ist es auch heute
nicht
fakt ist dabei dass ihr antrag gespickt
ist von unscharfen formulierungen ja es
ist richtig dass für die herausgabe von
zahlungsdaten von ip-adressen zu
anschlussinhaber in ein richtervorbehalt
besteht völlig zurecht im übrigen wie
ich finde dass durch diese zuordnung
anschlussinhaber in identifiziert werden
nicht aber zwingend täter ihnen sagen
sie selbst in ihrem antrag denn wenn
mehrere personen in einem haushalt einer
wg einem internetcafé den gleichen
zugang nutzen sind sie eben nicht klar
identifizierbaren daran ändert auch das
weitgehend zusammenhanglose erwähnt von
port nummern nichts diese ports
eindeutig einem endgerät nicht einem
oder einer nutzer in einem endgerät
zuzuordnen ist technisch noch weniger
praktikabel als die eindeutige zuordnung
einer ip-adresse zu anschlussinhaberin
sie versuchen unter dem vorwand
kinderschutz den datenschutz auszuhöhlen
die union sagt kinderschutz vor
datenschutz ich sage datenschutz ist
kinderschutz kindern im rahmen der
medienkompetenz beizubringen sparsam mit
ihren daten umzugehen sich nicht
identifizierbar zu machen und sich somit
von potenziellen tätern zu schützen das
ist gelebter datenschutz liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen das ist eine
sinnvolle präventionsmaßnahmen
ich zitiere an dieser stelle den
bundesdatenschutzbeauftragten professor
ulrich kelber aus dem herbst 20 21 der
auch sagte datenschutz ist kein
täterschutz datenschutz ist freiheits
schutz und überhaupt was ist denn
datenschutz datenschutz ist integraler
bestandteil des schutzes von menschen
der schutz unserer kommunikation unserer
privatsphäre und unseres
persönlichkeitsrechts das hat auch die
fortschritts koalition für sich erkannt
man sich diesen schutz insbesondere auch
im digitalen raum zum auftrag gemacht
identifizierungs pflicht lehnen wir ab
anonyme und pseudonyme online-nutzung
werden wir waren das steht so im
koalitionsvertrag
legitim ist die beschneidung dieser
grundrecht und des datenschutzes nur
aufgrund eines begründeten verdachts
unter richterlicher aufsicht keinesfalls
aber präventiv anlasslos und allgemein
sexuellen missbrauch von kindern im netz
und die darstellung davon bekämpfen wir
nicht dadurch dass wir mehr anlasslose
belastungen überwachung passieren oder
den datenschutz aushebeln unser fokus
sollte darauf liegen kinder schon vor
den anbahnung versuchen also vor den
missbrauchsfällen zu schützen dazu
gehört prävention das ist zum einen die
aufklärung über sichere nutzung moderner
kommunikationsmedien genauso wie die
aufklärung über körperliche und sexuelle
selbstbestimmung der kinder denn kinder
wissen ganz häufig wann was nicht okay
ist wir müssen mit ländern und kommunen
zusammenarbeiten um bei kindern deren
eltern ihren kontakt und
aufsichtspersonen ein bewusstsein für
die problematik zu schaffen in
mittel-und hilfen an die hand zu geben
missbrauchsfälle vor ort zu erkennen und
zu verhindern
dazu gehört auch die angemessene
ausstattung unserer behörden mit
personal im bereich des digitalen raums
insbesondere mit entsprechendem
fachpersonal einer zeitgemäßen
technischen ausstattung und dem nötigen
know how dies erstreckt sich
selbstverständlich auch auf die
strafermittlungsbehörden es darf nicht
sein dass ermittlungsverfahren zu lange
dauern oder nicht stattfinden weil es an
personal und oder an fähigkeiten mangelt
die darstellung von kindesmissbrauch
geht immer ein realer kindesmissbrauch
voraus täter in müssen schneller und
effektiver gefasst werden und wir sind
uns sicher dies lässt sich auch ohne
unverhältnismäßige eingriffe in digitale
bürgerrechte realisieren
wir brauchen mehr als kosmetische
politikum kinder wirksam zu schützen die
bekämpfung von kindesmissbrauch ist
nicht mit einer maßnahme zu erledigen es
ist eben nicht simpel es ist gar kein
rein technisches es ist ein
gesellschaftliches problem über das wir
hier reden der titel des antrags der cdu
csu fraktion laut kinderschutz vor
datenschutz mit der speicherung von
ip-adressen sexuellen kindesmissbrauch
wirksam bekämpfen das ist aus meiner
perspektive doppelt blanker hohn denn
liebe kolleginnen erstens datenschutz
ist kinderschutz er ist menschen schutz
und zweitens wird sexueller missbrauch
von kindern nur wirksam bekämpft durch
sinnvolle präventionsmaßnahmen durch
medienerziehung durch sensibilisierung
und durch opferschutz und dann durch die
aus gemessene ausstattung unserer
strafverfolgungsbehörden mit personal
technik und know how nicht aber mit
einem weiteren fragwürdigen
überwachungsinstrument das ist
das ist ein längerer weg das ist ein
grund rechtskonformer nachhaltiger und
effektiver wert herzlichen dank
vielen dank fürs ausgehen
dass nicht so viel geld dass wirklich
wichtigen mit allen fraktionen
[Applaus]
ich habe selbst vier bezaubernde kinder
das jüngste kam erst dieses jahr zur
welt wer wenn nicht wir väter und mütter
können nachvollziehen was es bedeutet
unsere kinder in das aktuelle chaos
unser science des stolzen landes zu
entlassen die unionsfraktion in ihrem
aktuellen antrag fordert die
vorratsdaten speicherung von ip-adressen
vor vorgeblich um kinder vor sexuellem
missbrauch zu schützen
in den händen dieser region cover sind
weitere überwachungs werkzeuge und über
bohren der macht hochtief erich
wehrmacht gibt bekommt weitere
abscheuliche sexualisierung von kindern
das bedeutet mehr kindesmissbrauch
sie kennen daniel content mitglieder
können und seine
unerträglichen aussagen wie der erotik
von fünfjährigen mädchen sie kennen die
unsägliche netflix serie securities die
sichern sexualisierten posen von kleinen
mädchen erhitzt
verwahrloste linke kultur normalisiert
die sexualisierung von kindern
genauso laut experten gehen auch die
pädophile vor aber sexualisierung von
kindern ist nicht normal und darf es
auch niemals werden schluss damit
hierzulande werden gez verweigerer oft
schwerer bestraft als manch prominentem
pädophile
schluss mit lachsen strafen schluss mit
verständnis und unterstützung
durch die machtpolitiker die
verantwortlichen für hunderte tabubrüche
niedere ideologie und schlussendlich die
fatalen entwicklung in den letzten
jahren versammeln sich hier im saal
der cdu plan würde viel mehr bewirken
dass rechtschaffene bürger bis auf die
knochen durchleuchtet werden werde
allerdings nutzen nur leitungen um die
ganze wertung verschlüsselungen um ihre
schändliche verbrechen zu vertuschen
der wahre grund für den vorstoß der
union steht fest die tiefe sehnsucht
nach kontrolle bespitzelung und
unterdrückung ja der gläserne bürger in
einer gar nicht zur typischen wählt der
absoluten kontrolle über das volk
der antrag der cdu ist eine
hinterlistige falle und ein trojanisches
pferd
die blütenweiße fassade des
vorgeschobenen team des schutzes hat
tiefe krise während das was sich
dahinter verbirgt ist ein angriff auf
die freiheit als unserer landsleute und
ein weiterer riesensprung richtung
totalüberwachung
ja zufahrten straftaten für
kinderschänder nein zum gläsernen bürger
wir sehen diesen antrag ab
vielen dank herr kollege schmidt
nächster redner ist der kollege helge
limburg
bin ich 19 der rechtspolitische sprecher
der fraktion bündnis 90 die grünen
herr präsident liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen als ich gehört habe dass die
union einen antrag einbringen wird zum
thema kinderschutz da habe ich mich
gefragt worüber werden wir reden über
die verbesserte zusammenarbeit über
ländergrenzen hinweg zwischen
jugendämtern polizei schulen und
ähnlichem oder werden wir reden über
konzepte zur stärkung des
selbstbewusstseins für kinder damit sie
offensiv nein sagen können sich selber
während selber hilfe suchen werden wir
reden über informations- und
beratungsangebot gebote für besorgte
erzieherin erzieher eltern und andere
verwandte nein über all das wollen sie
hier keine debatte führen sie schreiben
sie beschreiben auf anderthalb seiten ja
zu recht viel viele schreckliche
schlimme taten und die einzige
konsequenz die einzige schlussfolgerung
die sie daraus ziehen ist zum wiederholt
und wiederholten mal die
vorratsdatenspeicherung zu fordern dass
sie sehr sehr dünnen herr kollege kriegt
also sie wollen eine debatte über die
vorratsdatenspeicherung bereit dann
führen wir diese debatte zunächst einmal
ist in der tat viele polit kollegen
haben daran haben bereits darauf
hingewiesen ich darauf hinzuweisen dass
die vorratsdatenspeicherung eine kurze
wechselvolle und letztlich auf ganzer
linie gescheitert episode in diesem
rechtsstaat war und das war gut so liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
die vorratsdatenspeicherung war von
anfang an von anfang an ein fremdkörper
körper in unserem straff ermittlungs
system und zwar deshalb bei der
regelfall gern der strafprozessordnung
ist dass wir voraussetzungen schaffen
bedingungen rahmenbedingungen dafür
welche voraussetzungen der staat
bestimmte daten erheben darf bestimmt
ermittlungsmaßnahmen durchführen darf
nur die vorratsdatenspeicherung hat
zunächst einmal private dritte dazu
verpflichtet daten überhaupt zu sammeln
daten nur zu dem zweck zusammenhänge zu
speichern und auf zu geben damit der
staat später wegen der strafbank auf sie
zugreifen kann es ist gut dass dieser
fremdkörper beseitigt wurde
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen der union
es hilft den ermittlerinnen und
ermittlern auch nichts wirklich gar
nichts wenn sie zum wiederholten male
und zum wiederholten male und zum
wiederholten male mit ihrem kopf gegen
eine stahlbeton wand zu rennen versuchen
in der hoffnung doch irgendwie noch
irgendeine variante dieses mittels
durchzubekommen das nützt keinem
praktiker keiner praktikerin dieses auf
und ab der letzten jahre hü und hott und
dann wieder hin und vielleicht wieder
doch nicht hat jedenfalls keine
strafverfolgung gedient nein kommt
kommen sie endlich auf kommen sie
endlich aus dieser von diesem überholten
und geschichtlichen instrument darunter
gestalten sie doch mit uns mit der
fortschritts koalition zusammen und mit
minister buschmann die instrumente wie
wirksam und rechtssicher und grundrecht
schon sind nämlich die anlassbezogene
wie es in einem rechtsstaat sein sollte
die anlassbezogene speicherung im wege
des quick freeze von vorhandenen daten
das ist das grundrecht schonende mittel
was gleichzeitig ermittlungserfolg und
ermittlungsmaßnahmen möglich wäre schön
wenn sie dazu mal konkrete vorschläge
machen würden anstatt hier immer
vergangenheitsbezogene die bahn zu tun
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen natürlich
gehört es zu einem rechtsstaat das
schlimme verbrechen aufgeklärt werden
müssen und zum beispiel potter schon zu
viel richtiges gesagt ermittler
aufstocken zusammenarbeit stärken auch v
personen einschleusen in die szene bei
der
zeugenschutz zeugen schützen zeugen
stärken opfer geschützt unterstützen
damit sie auch aussagen auch
umfangreiche aussagen können und dafür
befähigung schütz werden kinder
insbesondere solchen verfahren stärker
betreuen das wären doch alles wirksame
maßnahmen hier ihr parteikollege ihr
parteikollege und kollege aus demselben
landesverband heckings in nordrhein
westfalen war da übrigens schon viel
viel weiter mit seinen konsequenzen aus
den fällen in lichte und anderswo es
wäre schön wenn sie so was sie diesen
antrag geschrieben hätten anstatt nur
dieser eine strukturdebatte
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen es gehört
zum wesen des rechtsstaates das ist eben
auch keine strafverfolgung um jeden
preis gibt es gehört zum wesen des
rechtsstaates dass du das hat das
bundesverfassungsgericht zu recht
ausgeführt
überwachungsmaßnahmen nicht zu einem
diffusen gefühl aller zu einem diffusen
gefühl allerdings überwacht seines
stetigen kontrolliert und überwacht
science führen dürfen aber genau das ist
doch die gefahr bei der vorgehen
vorschlagen anlasslosen massenhaften
speicherung von ip-adressen dass alle
die sich im internet bewege sich
überwacht fühlen und das ist ja
letztlich auch unmittelbare folge der
maßnahmen lieber
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
abschließend das tote pferd mit dem
etwas sperrigen namen
vorratsdatenspeicherung ist in diesem
land schon viele viele tode gestorben
anstatt wie die union immer wieder zu
versuchen es wieder zu beleben sollten
sie endlich absteigen und mit uns
gemeinsam an fortschrittlichen konzepten
arbeiten fehlt
vielen dank natürlich gegen beruf
als nächster reportedly ddr thorsten
lieb fdp fraktion
jetzt der stellvertretende vorsitzende
des rechtsausschusses
[Applaus]
sehr geehrter herr präsident
verehrte kolleginnen kollegen sehr
geehrte damen und herren auf der tribüne
der sexuelle missbrauch von kindern ist
eine besonders abscheuliche tat
besonders widerlich wenn es im
familiären und persönlichen umfeld
geschieht das macht mich gerade als
vater von vier kindern
fassungslos dass gerade in dem bereich
natürlich damit aller konsequenz dieser
fonds ist konsequenz des rechtsstaates
die täterinnen und täter zur
verantwortung gezogen werden müssen
daran kann und das hat er macht ja auch
hier niemand nicht der geringste zweifel
bestehen aber liebe kolleginnen kollegin
von der von der cdu kinderschutz vor
datenschutz wie der antrag lautet ich
muss offen sagen ich halte das schon für
einigermaßen perfide zwei richtige
zwei wichtige und fundamentale grund
rechtsprinzipien recht auf körperliche
unversehrtheit falle kinderschutz recht
auf informationelle selbstbestimmung zu
den selbstbestimmung so gegeneinander zu
spielen eine rangfolge hierzu bilden das
wird die wir ernst und der bedeutung
dieses thema alles andere als gerecht
liebe kolleginnen kollegen der
vermischen sich die nicht
zusammengehören und
das gerade vor dem hintergrund eben noch
mal innert die kollegin bea hat vorhin
an die sachlichkeit der debatte erinnert
beim anderen thema sind gut beraten auch
an dieser stelle zur sachlichkeit
zurückzukehren
richtig ist auch das ist schon mehrfach
erwähnt worden dass der bgh in seiner
entscheidung auch die möglichkeit
eröffnet hat ip adressen zu speichern
aber aber und das vermisse ich völlig
bei ihrem antrag und völlig bei der
positionierung der cdu csu fraktion das
ist drei andere wege noch gibt wie der
ogh geöffnet hat drei andere wege von
denen das eine das quick freeze
verfahren ist dass wir als koalition
durchsetzen wollen
und jetzt kann doch nicht richtig sein
einen solchen antrag zu stellen und
deswegen ärgert mich die
instrumentalisierung dieses themas
miteinander so
[Musik]
das dass sie sich mit den anderen themen
überhaupt nicht sachlich
auseinandersetzen das würde zu einem
seriösen antrag selbstverständlich
dazugehören
abschließend will ich auf einen ganz
bemerkenswerten absatz noch eingehen
ihres antrages kollegin hat es schon
erwähnt indem sie dafür sprechen für den
fall dass die ip-adresse genutzt wird
das noch die speicherung von technischen
begleit daten erforderlich sei ich will
das gar nicht technisch erörtern aber
eines müssen jedoch festhalten für die
debatte dieser punkt ist überhaupt gar
nicht angesprochen in der
ogh-entscheidung das ist überhaupt nicht
thema gewesen wir wissen gar nicht ob
das überhaupt grundrechtskonforme ist
statt also
statt also dass sie einen hand wir
formulieren mit jemand mit dem man
arbeiten kann formulieren sie etwas oder
auch zusätzliche rechtlichen risiken
entstehen und da möchte ich gerne ihre
reaktion sehen wir machen das unter php
als koalition stehen für eine
rechtskonforme lösung und die setzen
darum in latina
vielen dank herr kollege in berlin
nächster gegner ist das liege
christoph de vries cdu/csu-fraktion
[Applaus]
sogar der präsident liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen ich habe jetzt erst mal an
einer fachtagung zum thema sexueller
kindesmissbrauch im internet
teilgenommen dort waren alle fachleute
vertreten und was sie dort über die art
und weise des sexuellen missbrauchs an
kindern berichtet haben ist so
unvorstellbar dass ein fast die sprache
verschlägt einige haben das heute auch
schon gesagt das jüngste kind das live
im netz missbraucht wurde wo tausende
zuschauer gucken war noch nicht einmal
einen monat alt ein monat liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen und die täter
konnten bis heute nicht gefasst werden
und das kein einzelfall laut dem
international sind allein während der
korona pandemie die abo-zahlen im netz
noch einmal um 200 prozent gestiegen
europol verfügte im jahr 2020 allein
über 51 millionen bilder filme und texte
und wären wir hier sitzen und dieses
thema diskutieren werden über 200 bilder
und videos groß stunde weltweit
hochgeladen die verbreitung dieses
widerlichen material findet immer
rasanter statt und immer häufiger kommt
täter ungeschoren davon es ist
angesprochen worden ich hatte das die
bundesregierung gefragt
19.000 150 hinweise konnten nicht
verfolgt werden weil es in deutschland
keine pflicht der provider für die
speicherung von verkehrsdaten gibt und
um das mal ganz deutlich zu sagen alle
fachleute in den lenders kriminal ämtern
im bundeskriminalamt in den kinderschutz
organisationen fordern unisono eine
allgemeine zeitlich begrenzte
speicherung der ip-adressen und wir
fordern dass als union deshalb auch
meine damen und herren
es ist ganz klar es gibt kein besseres
schnelleres und effektiveres mittel zur
ermittlung der täter und weil das so ist
und weil der bundesjustizminister an
dieser stelle immer auf der bremse steht
will ich sie auch einmal ganz persönlich
fragen wollen sie wirklich weiter in
kauf nehmen dass tausende kinder sexuell
missbraucht werden und die täter
weiterhin nicht ermittelt werden können
und ich will ihnen auch die frage
stellen ist in der datenschutz denn
wirklich so heilig dass an dieser stelle
nicht allgemein aber an dieser stelle
die täter mehr schützt als die opfer
und ich will ihnen eine dritte frage
stellen wollen sie als justizminister
unsere ermittlungsbehörden eigentlich
bei ihrer wichtigen arbeit unterstützen
oder wollen sie weiter daran behindern
und das sind nicht meine fragen das sind
die fragen die der ehrenvorsitzende der
deutschen kinderhilfe in einer
pressemitteilung am 18 juni sinngemäß
auf die frage aufgeworfen hat und wir
stellen uns diese fragen eben auch herr
minister ich frage mich wie empathie los
muss man eigentlich sein um liberale
prinzipienreiterei bei der bekämpfung
von kindesmissbrauch über den
kinderschutz zu stellen wir reden hier
nicht über eine steckdosen verordnung
bruder ähnliches ist ihnen das ich habe
dafür überhaupt kein verständnis und ich
habe auch kein verständnis dafür dass
immer wieder der eindruck erweckt wird
mit einer befristeten speicherung von
ip-adressen und eine herausgabe auf
richterlichen beschluss wäre hier
staatlichen datenzugriff tür und tor
geöffnet das ist einfach unsinn meine
damen und herren das ihr immer wieder
dieser eindruck erweckt wird lassen sich
zum abschluss sagen willkommen zum
schluss bilden ich komme zum schluss wir
richten unseren hoffnungsvollen blick
hier an der stelle auf die
innenministerin feser die sich für die
speicherpflicht auf gesprochen hat herr
fiedler ich kann nur sagen unterstützen
sie bleiben sie hatten der stände mal
standhaft und wehrhaft gegen fdp und
grüne sie würden im kinderschutz in
deutschland wirklich einen großen dienst
erweisen vielen dank
christoph de vries war das für die
unionsfraktion und ja wenn sie fehler
die bundesinnenministerium hat sich für
die sicherung der ip-adressen von
computern ausgesprochen um den sexuellen
missbrauch von kindern im internet
besser verfolgen zu können das hat sie
in einem interview mit dem
deutschlandfunk vor kurzem gesagt
nächste rednerin carmen wegge für die
sozialdemokraten
sehr geehrter herr präsident sehr
geehrte kolleginnen und kollegen der
demokratischen parteien sehr geehrte
damen und herren die heutige debatte wir
haben es gerade gesehen ist ein
musterbeispiel aus dem lehrbuch des
ewigen klassiker wie fordere ich mehr
anlasslose überwachung ich erkläre das
kurz mal nehme ein verbrechen dass
wirklich jeder schrecklich findet zum
beispiel terrorismus sexuelle gewalt
gegen kinder man fordere dann technische
lösungen die man schon immer wollte hier
den klassiker der union die
vorratsdatenspeicherung man erntet den
großen aufschrei der bürgerrechtler
innen man schlägt zurück und bezeichnet
alle differenziert abwägenden oder
vorsichtigen grundrechts schützer
innentäter schützer man ruft haupt
kinderschutz vor datenschutz und frucht
hat man eine wunderschöne diskussion
werde er sich zwei laut brüllende
gruppen auf die bäume jagen und sich von
den baumkronen aus streiten aber dieses
spiel mache ich persönlich nicht mit ich
trage gerne etwas ruhe und
differenziertheit in der debatte bei
sexuelle
sexualisierte gewalt gegen kinder müssen
wir bekämpfen wir brauchen natürlich
auch technische lösungen aber vor allem
eine stärkung der prävention ich will
ihnen in drei schritten gerne erläutern
wie wir als spd-fraktion diese debatte
führen wollen erstens trauen wir uns
genauer hinzuschauen und nicht auf der
empörungswelle zu reiten worüber
sprechen wir beim gegenstand ihres
antrags anlass ihres antrags war der
anstieg der fälle die sich aus der
aktuellen sonderauswertung der
polizeilichen kriminalstatistik ergibt
von 20 20 auf 20 21 haben sich die
anzeigen zum straftatbestand herstellung
besitz und verbreitung von
kinderpornografischem material
verdoppelt was steckt hinter diesem
anstieg ich möchte ihnen gerne drei
gründe nennen erstens in den letzten
jahren haben bka und lka aber auch die
staatsanwaltschaften ihre kapazitäten
zur ermittlung von online kriminalität
stark ausgebaut wenn mehr polizistinnen
und staatsanwälte ermitteln werden sie
auch mehr finden und das ist auch gut so
zweitens was zeigt uns die polizeiliche
kriminalitätsstatistik genau sie erfasst
die anzeigen und die verdächtigen sie
teilten also nicht automatisch die taten
und täter und erst recht nicht wie viele
der ermittlungen am ende zur
rechtskräftigen verurteilungen geführt
haben sie hilft uns uns der wirklichkeit
anzunähern gibt aber nicht die exakte
wirklichkeit wieder und drittens 50
prozent der tatverdächtigen in der
kategorie verbreitung von
kinderpornografischem material sind
minderjährige die kinder und
jugendlichen sind zwischen 12 und 17
jahre alt sich tauschen unter
gleichaltrigen bilder von sich aus wobei
eine pädokriminelle absicht eher selten
unterstellt werden kann sie werden aber
durch diesen straftatbestand
kriminalisiert die
innenministerkonferenz hält bereits
jetzt eine rechtliche prüfung zum umgang
mit minder schweren fällen für
erforderlich da diese ermittlung so
viele ressourcen binden kommen wir zum
zweiten schritt unserer debatte was
bieten sie als problemlösung an sie
wollen eine rein technische lösung
nämlich eine speicherpflicht für sechs
monate von ip adressen bei den providern
wir verschließen uns nicht technischen
möglichkeiten im kampf gegen
kindesmissbrauch aber wir wollen
technische möglichkeiten an ihre
effektivität messen inwieweit die
ermittler in wirklich unterstützen
verbrechen zu entdecken und aufzuklären
die ermittlungen über ip adressen ist
nur ein ausschnitt davon sie nennen
ihrem antrag 19.000 150 fälle in diesen
fällen stand als einziger
identifizierungs ansatz lediglich die
adresse zur verfügung die dann aber
nicht mehr bei den providern gespeichert
war jeder fall der nicht aufgeklärt
werden kann muss uns natürlich besorgen
aber wenn sie mit einer zeit kommt dann
setzen sie bitte auch ins verhältnis
alles andere ist nur ein teil der
wahrheit die 19.000 fälle waren nämlich
innerhalb von fünf jahren 2017 bis 20 21
bei insgesamt 302 tausend meldungen nur
circa sechs prozent der fälle die
innenministerkonferenz prüft aktuell
welche sicherungs mechanismen und welche
sicherungs zeit von ip adressen für
erfolgreiche ermittlungsarbeit notwendig
erscheint wir sind also schon tätig aber
eben unaufgeregt drittens
der große und wichtigste schritt die
lösung von komplexen sozialen problemen
wollen wir auf allen ebenen denken auch
wenn es mühsam wird sie sprechen in
ihrem antrag vor allem über die
bekämpfung von abbildung von sexueller
gewalt gegen kinder wenig von der
bekämpfung der direkten sexuellen gewalt
gegen kinder wir wissen jedes welt
online entsteht offline das ist das
größere übel und hier müssen wir nicht
nur technische lösungen im
werkzeugkoffer haben wir müssen über
sensibilisierung im sozialen umfeld von
kindern über medienerziehung in kitas
und schulen über kinderfreundliche und
niederschwellige meldestellen off und
online sprechen ja das macht arbeit das
ist kleinteilig und langwierig ja dafür
r braucht brauchen wir die kommunen die
länder liebe union die lehrer/innen die
erzieherinnen die sozialarbeiter in dem
jugendamt die väter die mütter einfach
sehr sehr viele menschen eine
rechtsänderung zur
vorratsdatenspeicherung magda bequemer
erscheinen ist aber nicht so wirksam die
echte prävention und gesellschaftliche
debatten über echten kinderschutz und
zuletzt liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
von der union der kinder schützen will
schützt ihre rechte kinder sind
trägerinnen und träger von rechten
unterstützen wir uns doch dabei
kinderrechte ins grundgesetz zu
schreiben
sie doch den
kinderschutzgesetz und gesetz
dort steht nämlich wirklich weit vor
allen anderen normen und das müsste
ihnen dann ja gefallen vielen dank herr
kollege wir fahren hier sind bescheuert
und da gehen können sich entweder aber
das ist nicht nur ein parlamentarisches
ordnungsruf es wird
nächste reden das ging in richtung der
cdu csu fraktion diesen zwischenruf
hatte bundestags vizepräsident wolfgang
kubicki
anscheinend gehört und damit gerückt
liebe kolleginnen liebe cdu csu fraktion
auch wenn der erste satz ihrer
initiative bizarr ist sie haben recht
mit der feststellung
sexualisierte gewalt stellt eine
schwerste rechtsverletzung dar und ist
um gehört zu den abscheulichsten dingen
die einem jungen menschen angetan werden
kann dem müssen wir uns als gesellschaft
mit der notwendigen ernsthaftigkeit
widmen sie tun dies aber leider nicht
als ampelkoalition werden wir
sexualisierte gewalt gegen kinder
entschieden und wirkungsvoll bekämpfen
um hier nur drei vorhaben aus dem
koalitionsvertrag zu nennen wir werden
sich unabhängige beauftragte für fragen
des sexuellen kindesmissbrauch
gesetzlich verankern wir werden die
unabhängige aufarbeitung kommission
weiterführen und wir werden die
länderübergreifende zusammenarbeit im
kinderschutz verbessern
sie glauben dass das ziel allein mit der
speicherung von ip-adressen erreicht
werden kann zeugt von einem massiv
mangelnden verständnis der komplexität
dieses themas denn es darf jedoch nicht
nur um die frage kinderschutzhauses
datenschutz geben ihre versuche
verschiedene grundrechte gegeneinander
auszuspielen sind schlicht absurd
wenn das thema ist vielschichtig muss
umfassend betrachtet werden und ihr
antrag leistet das in keinster weise
ihre forderung ist ebenso reflexhaft wie
ineffektiv er wird dem thema nicht
gerecht und ihre forderungen schützt vor
allem kein einziges kind vor
sexualisierter gewalt denn um kinder
wirksam davor zu schützen offline wie
unser online braucht es viel mehr was
das für die sicherheitsbehörden bedeutet
haben eine ampel kolleginnen hier jetzt
schon sehr deutlich gemacht aber unser
ziel muss eigentlich sein dass möglichst
keine taten passieren und dafür müssen
wir viel früher ansetzen wir brauchen
prävention und schutzkonzepte in schulen
in kitas in sportvereinen in allen
einrichtungen der kinder und jugendhilfe
und auch das private umfeld müssen wir
in den blick nehmen denn viele taten
passieren in direkten sozialen nahrung
für effektive prävention braucht es eine
umfassende aufarbeitung der taten die
geschehen sind und die noch jeden tag
geschehen das heißt es muss angebote für
betroffene geben um über ihre
erfahrungen sprechen zu können sie
sollten die möglichkeit bekommen zu
sagen welche präventionsangebote
unterstützung und hilfe sie benötigten
denn es darf nicht vom zufall abhängen
betroffene zugang zu derartigen
angeboten haben oder eben auch nicht um
aufarbeitung zu stärken müssen also
verbindliche strukturen und
hilfsangebote geschaffen werden und das
sage ich auch als sozialarbeiterin die
bis vor zehn monaten im jugendamt
gearbeitet hat und tagtäglich mit dem
schutz von kindern beauftragt
wenn sie also ein ernsthaftes interesse
haben den kampf gegen sexualisierte
gewalt an kindern zu führen dann lassen
sie uns bitte darüber sprechen wie wir
die kooperation von allen beteiligten
institutionen voranbringen wie wir
funktionieren schutzkonzepte in allen
bereichen in denen sich kinder und
jugendliche bewegen etablieren wie wir
alle menschen für das thema und die
gewalt die kinder und jugendlichen
angetan wird sensibilisieren und wie wir
die arbeit der unabhängigen beauftragten
für fragen des sexuellen
kindesmissbrauch und der unabhängigen
aufarbeitung kommission stärken ich bin
gespannt auf ihre konstruktiven
vorschläge vielen dank
das horten kollege michael wittmann
herr präsident
bundesminister für staatssekretärin die
cdu csu fraktion hat aus gegebenem
anlass heute den antrag eingebracht den
kinderschutz dadurch zu verstärken dass
wir die speicherung von ip-adressen bei
sexuellem kindesmissbrauch
haben wollen um diesen zu bekämpfen und
nicht die vorratsdatenspeicherung und
insofern meine sehr verehrten damen und
herren gehen 90 prozent meiner vorredner
vollkommen am thema vorbei warum tun sie
dies weil sie in ihrer koalition keine
einigkeit erreichen können wie es in den
haushaltsberatungen deutlich mitgeteilt
haben weil in wirklichkeit sowohl grüne
als auch spd sich gerne unserem antrag
anschließen würden dieses aufgrund der
weigerung der fdp und ihres
bundesministers nicht können
ich darf mich direkt meinem vorredner
christoph pries anschließend der genau
wie auch alexander throm und günter
krings klar gesagt hätte wir stellen uns
hier unten hinter die
bundesinnenminister denn die heute
leider nicht da ist die selbst nun
erkannt hat nach vorheriger weigerung
seit wir den besuch im bka dass die
speicherung der ip-adressen und und da
wäre es halt gut wenn sie über
technische dinge reden dann auch wissen
wovon sie sprechen bei dynamischen bei
dynamischen ip-adressen der zuordnung
der sogenannten dot-nummer
zustimmen könnten denn sie hat
verstanden dass das notwendig ist und
das zu tun was sie hier angeblich
fordern nämlich die prävention und die
beste prävention für kindesmissbrauch
ist das fassen der täter
[Applaus]
weil darin und kindesmissbrauch und das
wurde immerhin richtig angesprochen hat
zwei tat ebenen es hat zunächst den
taten tat ebene des missbrauchs und zwar
der wehrlosesten mitglieder unserer
gesellschaft oder wenn ihr wenn sie da
so spöttisch über die festschreibung von
kinderrechten im grundgesetz sprechen
darüber können wir diskutieren darüber
können wir diskutieren aber darüber
spöttisch zu reden dass dieses
irgendetwas bewirken würde wenn ein ein
monate alter säugling missbraucht wird
das ist doch wirklich eine
unverschämtheit allen opfern gegenüber
diese opfer sind wehrlose kinder und um
die haben wir uns zu kümmern
ja und die zweite tag meine damen und
herren das ist die herstellung der
besitz und die verbreitung von
kinderpornografischen material das
angestiegen ist wie nie zuvor im netz
stattfindet und damit eine ebene
erreichte für die opfer noch
schwerwiegender ist die noch eine
größere last oben drauflegt und deswegen
möchten wir eines erreichen wir möchten
dass diese ip adressen anders los
gespeichert werden und
anlassbezogen zugegriffen werden können
wenn dafür vielleicht zb krieg wie sie
auch gemeint ist eben ein anlass
erkennbar geworden ist wenn ein anlass
in diesem zusammenhang erkennbar wird
ist die tat bereits erfolgt meine damen
und herren und ich kann nicht mehr
zurückverfolgen was sie für weitere
täter und netzwerke beinhaltet das kann
ich aber wenn ich in die ip adressen
reingehen kann und es war sogar von
ihnen gelobte innenminister von
nordrhein westfalen der leider
feststellen musste dass bei den beiden
fällen die wir dort zueinander hatten
das muss ich nur als kurz gucken wie wir
bis jetzt habe ich gerade nicht da dass
wir herrn namens kirchen und münster
durch die vielen gefälle konnte ich
nicht mehr zueinander ordnen dass jede
zusammenhang hält der stelle
festgestellt werden können das heißt wir
hätten weiter der zelle verhindern
können und darum geht es uns mit unserem
antrag und um nichts anderes die
zugriffe werden immer anlassbezogen
seien die verschlüsselung ist möglich es
geht um insbesondere im dynamischen
bereich hier danken schlüssel auf machen
zu können wir plädieren dafür dass wir
tatsächlich die kinder vorrangig
schützen ihr schutz geht vor
fehlgeleitet und viel verstanden im
datenschutz ich danke
ihr habt mich hilde wittmann für die
cdu/csu-fraktion und
jetzt hat noch mal die fdp das wort
manuel höferlin hier der letzte redner
zu diesem tagesordnungspunkt auf
grundlage eines antrags der
unionsfraktion wurde ja hier und wird
hier debattiert
wir sprechen heute über ein sehr ernstes
thema der die straftaten an die
schwächsten in der gesellschaft
erschüttert jeden von uns und das ist
auch der teil in dem wir uns absolut
einig sind wir müssen mit allen
rechtsstaatlichen mitteln diese
schwersten verbrechen bekämpfen das ist
der eine teil deutschlands
und ich habe sehr gut zugehört liebe
kollegen der union wenn sie sprechen es
passiert ja nichts wir machen symbol wir
müssen eine politik machen ich frag mich
manchmal heckings hätte fries was haben
sie 16 jahre lang eigentlich gemacht
weil 16 jahre haben sie immer wieder die
gleiche leier abgezogen und sind immer
wieder mit dem kopf gegen die wand
gerannt und frau widmann wenn sie sagen
wir hätten keine ahnung da lade ich sie
ein gerne mit mir mal über das atv 6
protokollen die privacy extensions zu
sprechen und dann haben wir noch weitere
ansatz könnte in diesem sitzen druck
geraten
sie rennen mit dem gleichen mittel das
unglaublich und nicht verhältnismäßig
ist immer wieder gegen eine mauer hinter
der die sexuellen straftaten gegen die
kinder stattfinden und die mauer heißt
nicht daten schützen sie dazu sogar
ihren versuchen sondern die mauer gegen
die sie immer wieder krachend scheitern
ist die mangelnde verfassungsmäßigkeit
ihrer vorschläge und wie ein kleines
trotziges kind hatten sie immer wieder
aus die vor staaten speicherung und bin
nennen sie einfach anders und das ist
total unangemessen hätten sie sagen wir
sollen verantwortungs politik
verantwortungsvolle politik machen das
ist verantwortungslos was sie tun
anstatt maßnahmen zu ergreifen die
umgesetzt werden hätten können wo sie
hinter der mauer die kinder hätten
schützen können kommen sie immer wieder
mit dem mittel das nicht durch beweis
aber ich mache meinen lassen sich eine
zwischenfrage
25 sekunden überzählig dann nachher
diese vielleicht wenn ihre erlaubnis der
präsident
die zwischenfrage zu lassen sie haben
gerade gesagt dass man
verfassungswidrige vorschläge machen
würde hier mit dem antrag der union
deswegen eine ganz einfache frage halten
sie den vorschlag der
bundesinnenministerium auch für
verfassungswidrig ich bin der meinung
dass man wenn man von einem gericht wie
dem audi a4 möglichkeiten vorgeschlagen
bekommt und eines davon ist eine
datenspeicherung mit der man schon
mehrfach gescheitert ist und sie es
anreichern mit einem weiteren punkt
nämlich weiteren eigenschaften da ist
das grob fahrlässiges spiegelt ihre
politik wieder der letzten jahre nämlich
möglichst nah bis leicht über die grenze
der verfassungsmäßigkeit zu gehen um
sich später von gerichten wieder
korrigieren zu lassen das ist nicht die
politik der fortschritts koalition wir
bringen richtigen ausgleich und ich
finde sämtlich wenn sie uns vorwerfen
wir würden uns nicht um die opfer
kümmern und wir dem ein anderes mittel
das a und das ist nachher
verantwortungsvolle und
verfassungsgemäßen politik
ich finde
ich finde es gibt viele möglichkeiten
wie man hinter die mauer kommt um zu den
opfern und den tätern zu kommen um dort
etwas zu machen wir haben ein anderes
mittel gewählt und nur weil ein anderes
mittel wählen ist das nicht nur
unangemessen sondern völlig unangebracht
und extrem populistisch uns vorzuwerfen
wir würden uns dem thema nicht nähern
und nicht verantwortungsvoll nähren
damit stellen sie sich in die
populistische ecke und deswegen werden
wir quick freeze werden wir einen login
falle auf den weg bringen das sind
mittel mit denen wir uns den ähren sie
in den bundesländern können dafür sorgen
dass bei den ermittlungsbehörden ki bei
der auswertung der bilder verwendet wird
das sperren sie sich nämlich im
konkreten fall das würde die stark
strapazierten ermittlungsbeamten und
beamten entsichert entlasten wir machen
fortschritte koalition außerdem die
grundlage regelmäßiger berichtspflichten
des unabhängigen beauftragten zur regel
und am ende und das ist mein letztes
wort meine damen und herren
damit
schaffen wir die möglichkeit was sie
nicht geschafft wenn man mich um die
mauer einfach drum rum zu gehen und zu
den opfern und zu den tätern zu kommen
anstatt wie sie immer wieder dagegen zu
rennen herzlich bedanken wenn man
solchen fällen herr letzter redner die
in wermelskirchen in nordrhein-westfalen
aufgedeckten fälle von schwersten
sexuellen kindesmissbrauch haben diese
alte debatte wieder neu entfacht nämlich
die über längere speicherfristen von
verbindungsdaten um die täter
identifizieren zu können
wer stimmt für diesen antrag das ist der
antrag der unionsfraktion der zu grunde
lag der rest des hauses damit ist dieser
antrag abgelehnt der hier nicht die
mehrheit gefunden hat deutschland wartet
ja auch noch auf ein urteil des
europäischen gerichtshofs zur
vorratsdatenspeicherung
und wird ja wie angekündigt im
koalitionsvertrag
zumindest dieses quick freeze verfahren
dann
weiter diskutieren und dazu eingesetzten
für vorliegt